are you able to speak about some of the
deals that were being made there and
what was being negotiated behind the
scenes because we know publicly there
was a lot said but there's also a lot of
closed door meetings that we didn't get
to see are you able to to talk about
that sure I mean Thomas Massey wall he
voted for McCarthy on every ballot he
was there with us in the back rooms
helping write a lot of the fiscal policy
that ended up undergirding the agreement
and MTG you know she is an inspirational
Force I consider her probably my closest
Ally in all of Congress and she uh
deserves to be on committees and what
the Democrats did to her was so wrong
and so egregious and I think that she
had an earlier understanding with
speaker McCarthy that she would get back
on committees that they would be
meaningful committees that they would
tailor to her skill set and I think that
was sufficient for her to support him we
sought some broader structural changes
we achieved those uh the changes and
concessions we got out of McCarthy are
only going to endure to the benefit of
MTG because she's one of our more
Dynamic and fearless members I like
Kevin's Behavior the last week McCarthy
oh yeah how would you rate his yeah look
at him being speaker of the house this
week well one of the things that was not
in the rules but was part of our
addendum agreement was that the 14 000
hours had to be released of the footage
from January 6th and the speaker has
custodial oversight of a lot of those
records and he made that commitment and
then today he reaffirmed it publicly
that that's exactly what we're going to
do so yeah that you know trust is a
series of Promises Kept and I believe
that McCarthy deserves the opportunity
to keep the promises he made and so far
he's on the right track is he going to
have a grudge against you
I don't know that I'm going to be on his
Christmas card list but you know it
doesn't like that that's not really what
it's about you know he knows very
clearly what my objectives are and what
it took to get us to go forward with a
speaker and he is performing to that
expectation it's you know it's it's not
personal for me it's business I'd love
to get you guys in together to debate I
live on the show that'd be hot well I
mean what what would the the best
outcome of that have been Jim Jordan or
or Byron Donald's look I I think that
Jim Jordan is our most talented member
I think he's our hardest working member
he is one of my mentors he inspires me
but you know it got to a point where
there were six holdouts where you don't
we didn't want to drive McCarthy into
the arms of the Democrats right so once
the margin gets that low McCarthy could
in theory have gone to the Democrats
gotten you know four five six of them to
get instant covid in exchange for
draining our subpoena Authority and then
he would have ascended to the
speakership anyway all of the features
of our deal would have dissolved and
then every time we didn't send a
subpoena to hold government accountable
he could have said well that's Matt
Gates's fault so we didn't want to put
him in that position the country in that
position the house in that position and
so that's why we crafted what we thought
was the a deal that was not reliant on
trust but that had clear enforcement
triggers Eric's walwell Adam Chef
they're getting removed from their
committees right yeah do you think
that's a good thing
yeah I think that the Democrats kind of
you know crossed the Rubicon on this
when they threw MTG and gosar off
committees without a basis and there is
sufficient basis with Schiff in
particular I agree and uh you know
swallow well now
I don't think this like the grave
swalwell emergency is the Fang Fang
thing I think it's more the role he
played in the Russia hoax like when you
go out there and say there's evidence
that the president United States is a
Russian agent and then you don't deliver
on that you shouldn't get to serve on
the major committees that have access to
the most sensitive Intelligence on the
planet Earth
I agree and Adam but like the Fang Fang
thing yeah poor thing yeah listen listen
the the the internet is not gonna like
what I have to say maybe but within the
Republican conference I am swalwell's
biggest defender on the Fang Fang thing
and here is why he was a city councilman
in the city of Dublin and some chick
showed up with money wanting to hook up
with him you think that like he's a
single guy like running around southern
or running around California and he's
supposed to have like the defensive
briefing to turn down some like hot
Chinese chick chick that was wanting to
like donate money and jump in bed with
him he wasn't a member of Congress he
didn't have access to intelligence the
what most sensitive information he was
working on was like the sewage system of
the city of Dublin so I think you
probably give the guy a break for that
well you don't give him a break for is
then come in here and weaving these
whole lies onto half truths to try to
destabilize the presidency in the
country that's far more egregious than
the Fang Fang thing was he with Fang
thing while he was in Congress no that
was when he was on the city council
somewhere in nowhere California oh but
there's also with Adam Chef the release
of phone records of private citizens and
Nunes yeah oh yeah well Schiff is truly
the worst member of Congress he is he I
mean he is uh it's like looking into the
eyes of evil with that guy he's really
gonna say I think he's an evil man yeah
he has no reflection
what is going on and if you bring garlic
around his like skin starts to burn I
haven't talked to him but I think he's
got that same mindset that he's like
these people are evil and then other
people like he's evil like what is going
on a breakdown of communication he held
up an envelope on TV saying that it was
proof Trump colluded with Russia or
whatever and that he couldn't show
anybody like that's what happened it's
been a while yeah well and then he like
made up
a a construct of a transcript between
zelinski and Trump that just didn't
happen it was just willed into existence
by his imagination and I mean he's done
such damage to our intelligence
community and like there is a place for
the United States to like know what's
going on in the world usually knowledge
is power right but the way he weaponized
it and really started with a lot of the
Obama people like do you say what you
will about Obama the guy was good at
vertically integrating Personnel in a
lot of these agencies where where the
bureaucracy would bend to their will
like if there's a fair critique of
trumpets that you know he was this great
Visionary but oftentimes the people that
were two three four layers down were
working against him and he didn't roll
into the presidency with this terrific
Rolodex of people that could go and
operate at that level whereas you know
Schiff Obama like these these people
were good at getting people in place to
drive action and we should learn from
that is it because they were hooked up
with the liberal economic order at the
time and like they just had all the
backing of right there's a whole
emphasis like if you're part of the
prevailing way of thinking the National
Security State the neoconservative
worldview there's an entire
infrastructure there to like build out
your career there are endowed
professional professorships there are
think tanks that are ready to give you
six figure jobs there's a like career
progression of jobs on the hill but if
you think differently you're kind of
hunted in a lot you know you're hunted
canceled they do everything to
compromise you and if that doesn't work
they try to destroy you what do you
there's a lot of compromise um
especially in Washington DC but but how
deep does the rabbit hole goal be go
because there's a lot of people talking
about you know the Deep State the
intelligence agencies having a lot of
control using a lot of extortion special
interests interest groups pulling the
strings here what's your understanding
of how things really work in Washington
DC compared to what the average American
kind of sees well I think like the most
corrupt
like
foray into this is like freshman
orientation because like you show up
here and I mean you know imagine showing
up from Northwest Arkansas from like you
know Southern Mississippi and you see
the architecture of DC they take you out
to like the finest steakhouse the best
wine you've ever had and co-located at
your table are the lobbyists for the
major special interests for the
Committees that you're interested that
you want to serve on so like I get here
and they're like oh Gates you want to be
on the armed services committee have you
met these defense contractors these are
the key lobbyists that round up the
defense money and they put you with them
from the very beginning and you sort of
get the joke that if you give your vote
card to the leadership and your calendar
to the lobby Corps you just kind of get
enveloped into a system that's there to
nurture you and protect you and keep you
out of Harm's Way and all it costs you
is your own belief set and I don't think
that's compromised so much as selling
out now you know that so that is like
step one and that catches a whole lot of
the people who to get here and then
beyond that if you kind of resist that
system then they do try to extort you
engage in anything they can do to
compromise you cancel you find some joke
that you liked on Instagram years ago
that like doesn't fit with the mores of
this time find some email that you are
on like the forward chain of it's like
some basis to say that you're a white
supremacist or you're you know some sort
of unacceptable human the Campion polite
company and uh you know then if that
doesn't work it's abject destruction
through the political process where
there are
many many dollars lined up solely for
the extermination of those who push back
against against the narrative yeah this
is detailed extensively in books like
the the economic Hitman that I think are
definitely worth reading and checking
out here but talking to previous members
of Congress it's really kind of daunting
to see what they have to go through how
much pressure they have to go through
how much agreement they have to agree to
before even getting into some of those
positions of power
um from the dues it's money I mean it's
there's specific dollar amounts I mean I
remember you know going in and saying
well I want to be on the armed services
committee and someone looked me dead in
the eye and said well that'll be seventy
five thousand dollars that you owe to
the leadership funds and and to the
Republican Congressional committee and
so you know I I go home and think well
you know part of you wants to say screw
you or like are you wearing a wire
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored third members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time